[Music]
it will be a spectacle Britain hasn't
seen in 70 years
filled with plenty of Pomp and pageantry
the king's coronation promises the
largest armed forces celebration in a
generation
more than 6 000 Personnel will play a
key part
Sailors soldiers and aviators taking
part in the processions
and a 60 aircraft fly past over the mile
in central London
the Armed Forces always bring a Panache
to British ceremonial and for the six
thousand that will be taking part from
the Navy the Army and the Air Force both
of the United Kingdom and of other
Commonwealth Nations it'll be Splendid
and for all of them taking part they'll
never forget it because they'll bring
their excellence and make a profound and
special expression of that service on
the Streets of London
thousands of invitations for front row
seats for all of it have been sent out
here outside Buckingham Palace a
grandstand will seat nearly 4 000 NHS
workers veterans social Care staff and
charity reps they're going to have a
prime view of the events that take place
on the day including the processions the
fly past and the Royal appearance on the
balcony
[Applause]
harvest in Westminster Abbey will be
pivotal
a grand ceremony preserving tradition
it's where we'll hear a blend of Music
both old and new selected by the king
himself
[Music]
Debbie Wiseman composed two of the
pieces I mean the first piece is more
traditional more you might expect to
hear as a coronation
um you know we're so used to hearing
Elgar and Huber parry and Vaughn
Williams and Handel coronations and that
music is very traditional and
celebratory and Royal and Majestic the
second piece was originally going to be
written for the same group of people for
the Westminster Abbey choir and then
King Charles
made a very personal request that he'd
love a gospel choir at the coronation
and so I had the absolute thrill of
being able to take that music and then
rework it slightly for the Gospel Choir
the coronation will Mark a day of unity
a day of tradition a day of Celebration
Aisha zahid Sky News